we are in Liberty City where I grew up
this is home this is where the magics
happen there's something about just
being from this area in general where
you carry yourself a certain way during
my era obviously it was warzone my out
as a young kid as explained to me by my
grandparents at the time was football I
didn't know how important it was was a
kid we was running around playing
football plant throw up tackling the
grass and stuff like that we was just
interesting that's beautiful it's
beautiful it's fun it's competitive
I'm glad I was brought up there I had to
live here
Liberty City optimist we are the beacon
of the community but these is picked us
up and showed us love but the dealers
showed us how a partnership getting
groups that partnership ended up
becoming me you know it look let's do it
makers lab in Miami dev sitting team
down and then they'll tell the kids all
right Joshu draw click draw a sneaker
you don't make your own sneaker and have
them being able to design some of these
shoes and put what they like on paper is
amazing fast forward to right now and
the D this is now building a feel that
Miami Edison that's the first turf field
in miami-dade county there's no words to
explain how special this is for the
entire community think about what we had
to play with potholes rolling your
ankles the keys man so they can
experience and know what it's going to
feel like once you get I can come here
any time it touch one of the kids and
give some motivation give hope I come
from the same spot we don't continue to
build him because there's so much talent
that come through here and all sports
it's important for us to to build right
here in our backyard and now our home it
takes a total team to make things happen
and with this community and changing the
kid's life is a team sport
[Music]